it was down to three when Steve Carell  left the show Allison Jones was looking  through memorabilia for Steve like was  there something from his first audition  or whatever and she came to like his  party when he was leaving and she pulled  me aside she was like I didn't really  find that much for Steve but I found  this I thought you'd be interested and  this was like a paper it had been seven  eight years kind of discolored I have it  in my office now and it just said Kevin  Malone and it's in my office but I don't  remember the order it wasn't in order  but it it said one two and three Brian  Baumgartner Eric Stone Street and Jorge  Garcia so at that time that's before  lost with Jorge that's before Modern  Family with Eric and there there I am  and wow rain Wilson always says to me  too bad Eric didn't get it because I'd  be much richer now if I had gone to  minor family but um